Allah says in surah fat chapter number
35 verse number 15 that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala you are in need of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala Allah is free of all
needs worthy of all praises so Allah
subhananau wa ta'ala does not require
anyone and anything but everything is
dependent on him so he is asking us to
praise him so that when we praise him we
will follow his advice
given in the Quran and it will benefit
us. So he is asking us to praise him for
our benefit not for his
benefit. It will benefit us not
him. For
example,
if there is a married couple, husband
wife who does not get children for many
years, they feel sad because they have
no children.
You have another
example that a married couple they have
a
child and after a few years the child
dies. So the couple to whom a child was
born and after a few years the child
dies he feels more
sad than the first couple who had no
children. Let me give you one more
example. There is a couple who have a
child. They bring him up with love and
affection. Take care of him. He becomes
adult. After he becomes adult, 20 years,
30 years, 35 years, he starts disres
disrespecting the
parent. Forget about taking care of the
parent. When the parent get old, he
starts disrespecting the parent.
He starts using foul language against
the parent. What will happen to such a
parent? This parent will feel more bad
than the first two
parents. It is better not to have a
child than have a child and he dies or
to have a child and he become
disobedient, disrespectful, abusive.
Allah says in the Quran in surah Isra
chapter number
17 verse number 23 and 24 we have
ordained for the human
beings that they should worship only one
god and they should be kind to the
parents and if one of them or both of
them reach old age do not say a word of
contempt don't say of to them Allah says
if one of your parent or both of your
parents reach old age do not say of to
them but lower to them your wing of
humility and pray to the
Lord that cherish them as they cherish
me childhood. So Allah is saying in the
Quran in surah Sarah chapter 17 verse
number 23 and 24 that after worship of
Allah is respecting and being obedient
to your parent and imagine that child is
disobedient. Will you call him a good
human being?
The parents have taken
care of that child from the time he was
born till he becomes
adult. Gives him all the luxury and
later on he is disrespectful. He's
abusive. Surely no one will consider him
to be good human being. Now
imagine we as human beings we are not
thankful to Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
who is million times better than our
parents our creator our Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala who has given us this
life who has given all these facilities
he's our
creator he deserves multiple time more
respect than a parent so imagine
If we do not thank
him, we do not respect him, we would be
the worst human being.